4dconcept est une entreprise prestataire
en informatique les 50 collaborateurs de
la société travaille à saint quentin en
yvelines lyon ou encore toulouse
c'est pour cette raison que le
recrutement est très important pour
l'entreprise qui ne cesse de s'agrandir
mais recruter n'est pas simple la
difficulté pour nous c'est de
d'intéresser les candidats à travailler
dans une pme il faut savoir que beaucoup
de ss2i ou de grosses entreprises
appelées les ingénieurs qui sortent de
l'école
parce que ils ont déjà le côté grands
comptes grand client ou alors dans une
ss2i aussi vous faites partie d'une
d'une grosse
entreprise qui va vous permettre de
travailler à différents endroits pour
différents clients donc qui peut être
aussi une source de d'expérience pour
les jeunes candidats donc trouver des
candidats qui s'intéresse à une pme
c'est un peu plus dur quand ils sont
jeunes pour remédier à ces difficultés
pour recruter des candidats comme des
ingénieurs informatiques l'entreprise
utilise plusieurs solutions elle fait
appel à des cabinets de recrutement
poste des annonces sur internet ou use
des réseaux sociaux ce qui permet aussi
à l'entreprise 4dconcept d'affiner sa
sélection elle souhaite s'exporter à
l'international
c'est potentiellement ce projet que nous
avons devant nous quel développement à
l'international et qui pourrait nous
amener à faire un développement plus
important que celui que nous avions
prévu de faire avec entre autres la
compétence de langue également puisque
en fait dans nos outils il ya toujours
besoin d'un accompagnement chez nos
clients donc en fait on installe des
solutions chez nos clients et ont fait
l'accompagnement la formation la mise en
oeuvre est institué et donc en fait nos
collaborateurs doivent aller faire ses
accompagnements chez les clients donc
forcément le l'international nécessitera
en fait également la maîtrise de la
langue
l'entreprise réalise une croissance de
15 à 20% par an avec une telle évolution
le recrutement est un défi majeur pour
la pme qui souhaitent continuer à offrir
aux entreprises un service de qualité